this matters now to our guest host
Howard Ward is a gamco Mr ward has been
long and right he maintains that
optimism into the new year stocks will
prosper on okay revenues better than
okay earnings growth and use of ample
cash it will ensue we need to get to the
details right now what's distinct now
from February of 2009. from February
2009 oh my goodness well things are a
lot richer price now than they were then
well uh you're talking 15 into 16 times
forward earnings on the market right now
with a just under a two percent dividend
yield earnings are growing I think the
third quarter earnings growth is about
nine percent I would expect that 2015 is
going to be similar to that eight nine
ten percent that's above consensus I
think that's where the economy is going
with with some acceleration uh so
importantly confidence is back we're
gonna 2015 is going to be the fifth
record year for GDP growth and profits
and so I do think that confidence plays
a huge role in the economy and the stock
market how do you guys is what I'm going
to call Value not value trap buyers
respond to people like Robert Schiller
that would suggest giving any kind of
ratio analysis were richly priced
well I'm going to disagree with Mr
Schiller's work because it's backward
looking now I know it has some real
historical validity right so I'm not
going to just dismiss it out of hand but
my focus has to be on the next 12 months
the next 24 months not on the average of
the past the stock market is pricing
itself on the future it is not pricing
itself on the pass okay so you're
optimistic about the future what about
technology and particularly cloud-based
the shift to Cloud not Apple but the
hardware kind of companies like IBM and
Cisco when you look at them is their
extraordinary value there
I think you have to be very careful
there and then you mentioned the cloud
the cloud has been enormously disruptive
for a lot of these big Legacy Enterprise
Big Iron type companies
the era where you could sell a million
dollar box with a big service agreement
attached to it is not what it was there
are lots of alternatives for that
customer base that are far cheaper and
so I think that some of those companies
are really going to be challenged from a
growth perspective they do throw off a
lot of cash they may ultimately get more
revenues from the cloud and becomes a
positive for them but right now the
cloud well it might be their future it's
ahead okay well there's a professional
perspective